well you may or may not have noticed it
but people who earn money on the website
only fans may have a bad case of
whiplash tonight last week the website
announced that it would no longer allow
sexually explicit content on its
platform now that is like telling movie
theaters that they can no longer show
films
apparently only fans has a porn problem
in the eyes of credit card companies or
i should say had a problem today only
fans reversed its decision saying there
will be no porn ban on the site
only fans has 150 million users
worldwide and they pay to see content
much of it adult content the company
pays out a whopping 300 million dollars
every month to content creators
well needless to say with earnings like
that size does matter on only fans did
the decision to ban adult content on the
site signal a ratcheting up of a war
against porn well my next guest tonight
is himself an adult performer and
producer hunter johnson joins me tonight
from right here in berlin hunter it's
good to have you on the program let me
just ask you what do you make of this
this u-turn today from only fans
honestly none of us have any idea what's
happening today it has been absolutely
like you said whiplash
we had kind of seen the uh
the change coming we've kind of seen how
one of these big sites was gonna get
kicked out with the uh
evangelical right
wing in america really pushing for it
but this has changed we didn't see that
coming i thought it was gonna be all and
less
what about the accusations that have
been made
about yeah the content only fans that
you know that the moderation is
substandard that the site tolerates um
illegal content and it's lenient on
creators who post such content i mean
don't aren't these criticisms that they
deserve scrutiny
scrutiny sure i think that we should
always be fighting to try to um cut back
on human trafficking and
anything that's bad for um
sex workers in general the issue is that
since the american legislation the
foster since sesta went through which
very much pushed by the american right
wing
we've seen the uh a small group called
exodus cry which is an american
fundamentalist christian group
lobbying very very hard on the
payment processors mastercard and visa
all things can be controlled porn is in
general controlled by the payment
processors you see them being charged at
rates of 13 20 because sex work and porn
is considered by them to be high risk
which we're not it's not high risk
it's
safe
and
careful sex workers working from home
only fans is a
mostly women
site that is uh has allowed people to
work in do sex work in a safe and caring
fashion yeah let me ask you about let me
ask you about that
the platform really made its fortune you
could say on the backs of these sex
workers and
the the news from last week and this
week gives the impression that it's
turned its back
on these people
is that how you see it
absolutely
i mean
absolutely it's money um controlling the
flow
i'm gonna control the flow of morality
i mean only fans started and really took
off last year in the pandemic when it
allowed people to really explore a new
way of making money from home when they
didn't have other ways to make money a
lot of people know that
this turned porn and sex work to the
mainstream a lot of people who have
never had the chance to try before got
their chance
giving the only fans creators and
investors i mean
billions of dollars what was it the
weekly payout to uh
uh creators was roughly 300 million
dollars i think right right
i mean
yeah it's a huge amount of weight 20 of
which went to only fans which is
honestly not that much and uh comparison
to other uh porn sites like canning
sites usually take about 40 to 60
this is the best site
if you want to make
good as a creators content creator as
someone working from home if you want to
make money and create your own uh
public uh you're on your own
group
well we'll be following this story so
yeah yeah hunter we appreciate you
giving us a unique perspective on this
hunter thompson joining us from here in
berlin tonight thank you
thanks
you